lena sandgren dp and i both agree film  just looks so much better than imax  i think that was probably one of the  more exciting things the negative on  that film your frame is that big the  amount of information the detail that's  on there  the feeling  if you go to the cinema and watch  something on that scale it's sort of  unparalleled  just to be able to shoot that much with  those cameras was pretty amazing  the more we shot with them as difficult  as they can be the more in love we  became with what you could do with an  imax camera  [Music]  bond films are beautiful films usually  and this is just upsetting  it's already larger than life and then  it gets extra larger than life  you